we're going to talk about the
relationship between pH and PKA and
buffers and specifically we're going to
be talking mostly about this in terms of
the henderson-hasselbalch equation but
before we go to the henderson
hasselbalch equation which i am going to
assume you've seen before and if not we
have some other videos introducing it
and also deriving it let's do a quick
review of what exactly is a buffer so a
buffer is something that contains an
aqueous solution in aqueous solution
it's something that contains both a weak
acid which generically we write as H a
and it also contains in equilibrium it's
con the conjugate base of our acid so a
- this is as written it's the acid
dissociation reaction for H a and since
it's in equilibrium we can write an
expression called ka which is just the
equilibrium constant for this equation
and it just has a special name because
it happens to be for the dissociation of
an acid KA is just equal to h3o plus
times a - all over the concentration of
H a and we don't include water because
it's a pure liquid so we assume that the
concentration is always 1 based on this
expression for ka
we can and do in the separate video
derive the henderson-hasselbalch
equation so the henderson hasselbalch
equation just says that the pH is equal
to the pKa plus the log of a minus over
H a
where AJ is our weak acid and a - is its
conjugate base and as you can see up
here an acid and its conjugate base are
just related by the fact that the acid
has an extra H we can rearrange the
henderson-hasselbalch equation to get a
lot of different kinds of information
one kind of problem you see a lot is for
some buffer you know they might ask you
Oh what's the pH and then that means you
probably know the pKa and you know the
concentrations of a - an H a the other
thing that you can use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation to tell
you is the relationship between a - and
H a which is something you might want to
know a lot of times you just want to
know you know what's in your solution
depending on what you want to do to your
solution if you want to add things to it
maybe you want to add some acid you want
to add some base you want to know what's
going on the henderson hasselbalch
equation gives you a really quick and
easy way of doing that so what we're
going to do is we're going to rearrange
this equation to solve for this ratio
that way you might be interested in so
we're going to subtract PKA from both
sides and that gives us a log of a minus
over H a and I don't know about you but
I actually find well I find logs not
super intuitive sometimes so I'm
actually going to get rid of the log by
raising both sides to the tenth power so
that gives us 10 to the pH - PKA is
equal to a - over H a so what does this
tell us it might not look like it tells
us a whole lot more but actually it
tells us a lot it tells us about the
relished relative relationship in size
between a - and H a concentration and
it's saying that these two things are
related to the relative size of pH and
PKA so if we look at this we can derive
a couple relationships we're saying that
pH versus PKA this relationship
can tell us about a - over H a which is
a ratio but that in turn we can relate
to just the relative size of H a versus
a so let's go ahead and go look at all
the possible scenarios
for these three things we're going to
start with the simplest possible
scenario which is that pH is equal to
PKA when pH is equal to PKA we're
raising 10 to the 0th power so anything
to the zeroth power is equal to 1 which
tells us that this ratio is equal to 1
and if a - concentration over H a
concentration is equal to 1 that means
that they have the same concentration I
forgot a minus sign there this is a
really helpful thing to remember anytime
you have a buffer and the pH of your
solution is equal to the pKa of your
buffer you immediately know that the
concentration of your acid and its
conjugate base are the same and this
comes up a lot not just when you're
talking about buffers by themselves but
also when you're doing titrations and
the point in your titration where the H
a is equal to a minus is called the half
equivalence point half equivalence point
and if you haven't learned about buffers
that's ok or sorry if you haven't
learned about titration yet that's
totally fine just ignore what I just
said but if you have the moral is just
that it's really this is a really really
important relationship that it's really
helpful to remember and I said really a
lot there so there are two other
possibilities for pH and PKA we can have
a pH that's greater than PKA for your
buffer and you can have a pH that is
less than your PKA for your buffer so if
your pH is bigger than your PKA then
this term up here 10 - the pH - PKA is
going to be positive and when you raise
10 to a positive number
when you raise 10 to a positive number
you get a ratio that is greater
and one so if our ratio a minus over H a
is greater than one that tells us that a
minus the numerator is actually greater
than the denominator H a so if you know
the pH and you know it's bigger than the
pKa of your buffer buffers acid to be
more specific then you immediately know
that you have more conjugate base around
then your acid the last scenario pH is
less than PKA well in that case we're
raising 10 to a negative number because
we're subtracting a bigger number from a
smaller number and that means that our
ratio a - over H a is actually less than
one so that tells us that our
denominator H a is actually bigger than
our numerator so just to wrap up we can
look at the henderson hasselbalch
equation and we can just look at the
relationship between PKA and pH and
depending on whether they're equal to
each other or one is bigger than the
other we can immediately know what the
relationship is between our acid and its
conjugate base in our solution it's very
easy to derive we did it in just a few
minutes so it's okay if you don't
remember this all the time I usually
just remember that pH equals PKA means
they have the same concentration and
then if I forget I will derive the other
relation